hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i am one of your hosts reza
aslan
and i'm another one of your hosts rain
wilson hello everybody
hello rain hey this is a very special uh
episode this is
actually a a re-airing of an episode
that we did a little while ago
uh called uh are you part of nature
where we went to uh the site it was one
of the few on-site episodes we've ever
done which by the way we should do a lot
more of those that was fun why why would
we do it for fun it was super fun many
of you have probably heard of the
documentary the biggest little farm
well not far from my house in somas
california is
the site of the biggest little farm and
we went over there we talked to john and
molly chester
um
the kind of filmmaker
caterers turned
farmers regenerative farmers
and um just a brilliant documentary from
about i don't know five years ago or so
um
really
insightful and uh and beautiful to
behold and we got to go visit
the pigs and the corn and the worms
there were so many worms do you remember
the worms reza oh so much warm poop so
who knew how important worm poop was
well now we do
i mean has kept our planet going oh yeah
yes yes yeah we would all be we would
all be dead if it weren't for those
worms and their poop and you know here
they are just an average couple again
there's nothing all that extraordinary
about john and molly they're just like
you know an
l.a couple who lived in a an apartment
yeah
and
uh you know they did what we all do
every once in a while like you you watch
tv or like you know you watch the state
of the world and you're like man maybe
we should just go and and start a farm
somewhere and
and get out and then you move on you
turn you turn on netflix and you keep
going but they actually did it they they
have developed a fully sustainable farm
on 200 acres outside of los angeles of
all places
and
as rain said the the documentary was a
huge hit in fact it was such a hit that
they did a sequel
that's right so just a couple months ago
the biggest little farm the return
was released on earth day april 22nd
2022 and disney plus
taking you back to
see all their pigs and their corn and
their geese and their snails and all
their worms and their worm poop and all
of the other stars of the original this
is a sequel i can really get behind reza
forget all those star wars and marvel
sequels i'm talking about biggest little
farm the sequel
the multiverse of madness biggest little
farm
exactly since there's a sequel to uh the
documentary we thought we would do a
sequel to the podcast that we had with
them uh to reflect um and highlight you
know the the biodiversity of the planet
and the interconnectedness of nature um
that's i think the thing that really
uh brought us to john and molly's uh
farm um the story that they have about
how they transform this 200 acres of
dirt basically into
um you know a a single
almost micro uh organism right these 200
acres
that are completely sustained and all
the challenges that they had and
and just the beauty of it
and of course the lesson here uh is the
lesson that is reflected in the title of
the show which is that
we are part of nature that there is no
division between us
reza it's avatar it's just avatar
you know it's avatar it's cameron it's a
giant tree that gives life and the roots
from the soil and the bugs support the
thing and the blue people dance around
it's all interconnected um it's such a
beautiful philosophy that john and molly
have uh in the creation of and running
of this farm uh super inspiring it was
so great i remember it as if it was
yesterday
being on that farm pre-covered and um
and sitting down in their living room
taking a tour and sitting down in their
living room and having this really
profound discussion really excited for
you milkshakers to check it out that's
right and as as uh
anticipated as the avatar sequel
is
so
how are we uh filled with
the the same anticipation for the sequel
not just the biggest little farm but to
the podcast episode about the biggest
little farm so enjoy
hi there i'm raine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and today we're talking about worm
poop wait wait a minute i thought we
were talking about the circle of life
you know the
miracle of humans reconnecting to the
earth our mother earth and how we can be
a positive force for the the beauty of
nature yes yes we're gonna talk about
all those things
but also worm poop
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
so rain uh you know uh my family just
got
chickens we eat
yeah we made ourselves a little chicken
coop we
we've got you didn't make yourself a
chicken coop you bought a chicken coop
well we
nailed it together that's something it
has something it came in pieces more
than i've done and we painted it in
stuff and we filled it with chicken how
many chickens
well it started out as eight chickens
and then one day we went in there and
one of the chickens was a bloody mess
and there was no sign of forced entry
so i have a feeling like all the other
chickens chicken and cannibals it was
chicken cannibals they ganged up on that
one chicken the
the dark side of the circle of life that
people don't talk about the idea was
everyone kept telling us like oh you're
gonna get all these eggs more eggs than
you could ever hope for all these free
eggs we eat a lot of eggs in my family
as you know i have 47 children yes and
we eat a lot of eggs okay and you know
what they didn't tell you
is that chickens eat like five hundred
dollars worth of food a week like i mean
so you get thirty seven dollars worth of
eggs after spending five hundred dollars
in grain yeah exactly but that's you
know that's i i feel like a farmer i
feel a little bit like a farmer but if
you let them out to run around your yard
then they're going to eat uh other bugs
and stuff like that right they eat those
bugs they do that we also have bees we
have some bees we're basically preparing
for the zombie apocalypse wow you've got
bees you've got honey and eggs in your
place that's good to know mental note
what about you i mean you got like a
little mini font yeah we got a little
mini farm you know we got a couple of
pigs pot-bellied pigs as pets in the
backyard um my wife has got some horses
and a donkey
and i think we've been over the zonkey
yeah i think our our listeners know all
about the zonkey um but they're on a
horse farm that's a little further away
from our house but how often are you in
nature like really in nature of you do
you get in touch with nature very often
i mean i don't know i feel like the idea
was that having
chickens and having bees and like a
little garden that that would that would
you know make me a little bit closer and
make me understand kind of how this
whole
ecosystem that is the earth would come
together but you know
not really
what is the price that we pay by not
being regularly connected with nature
there's i think something
magical is lost when when we lose that
connection but here's here's the point
that i'm making is i feel like
most people
would say
yeah but that's i mean you're asking me
to give up everything like okay so i
have some chickens in the backyard i got
a zonkey in the backyard like that's
that's the closest
that most of us are ever going to get
to sort of truly
transforming our lives to kind of live
off the earth i'm not going to get
closer let's let's face it it's a lot of
work
i mean [ __ ] it's like it's i have this
dream of like i wanna live in a farm and
animals and bees and butterflies
everywhere it's like wait a minute no
you've gotta compost and spread manure
and and till and the harvest and keep
out the bugs yeah you know hire people
and fire people and
yeah it's it's it's a lot of work but
you know
when humanity was connected to the earth
i think there was a lot to be gained
from
yeah you know connection to the seasons
you know the circle of life the cycle of
life and death a recognition of the the
deep connection that we have
with the other living
beings on this planet
the very notion that the planet itself
is a sort of a single bio organism it's
an ecosphere that we're a part of yeah
we have lost all of that yeah and and i
do think that
it's a it's a crucial part of every
person's
journey is to a constant like
reconnection
with the natural world because
we are these meat puppets and soon these
little meat puppet suits that we're
wearing are gonna schluff away and
that's part of the miracle of nature as
well and so i guess the question is
what happens
to us when we
abandon the the modern disconnected
life that we are living now
and try to actually go back right right
go back and to our sort of prehistoric
selves right let's
become a part of that circle let's
implant ourselves in that
ecosystem let's let it let's let it
control us instead of us trying to
control it well
as a matter of fact dearest listener
reza and i saw an amazing film it's
called biggest little farm as a
documentary film made by molly and john
chester so so cute such a great movie
and
it's it's very simple
and so profound so profound at the same
time i i wept like three times in the
middle of this movie this couple are the
farmers and owners of apricot lane farms
it's just outside of los angeles they
had like 200 acres and that that brought
back to life and they're not like
professional farmers no they're just
like you and me and they went back to
the land
we had the opportunity to go visit them
and uh check out the farm and talk to
them about all of these life's big
questions surrounding nature and
it was an amazing
conversation and journey
so molly and john um
i'm curious
molly you had said that you had had no
farm experience why how did you get in
on on this like what made you think to
yourself i'm gonna go from no experience
uh with farming to
creating this kind of unique farm
environment
yeah it wasn't it didn't really happen
in that kind of a thought process it
more happened from the continual solving
of a problem and a need and um in my 20s
i dealt with some different health
issues and in solving that i became
really connected into how what you eat
affects how you feel on a very basic
level and became then fascinated with
the culinary side of that and went to
culinary school where i began learning
more and more about what nutrition and
how to prepare nutritious food in the
kitchen really meant and when you get
down to it there it becomes not only
about the choices you can make in a
kitchen which are like soaking sprouting
fermenting things like that that bring
life into the food but then what are the
choices the farmer is making because
what you start with and how nutritious
that food is is really
that's where you start that's you only
have that to start with so from there i
then began working with clients and
tried to find farmers who were raising
food in this way that i wanted to feed
clients and our own family and we found
a lot of really amazing farmers but we
could not find really fabulous eggs so
we started talking about what if we did
eggs and pulled out all the stops and
did them just a hundred percent the way
that we would want them to be and at the
same time we had a dog who was barking
his head off and we had this very you
know novice idea that we could have a
farm and that would solve the dog's
problem we'd have all this amazing food
and grow anything that we wanted to have
and so it started there really and then
john had a little more background in
farming which helped he knew how to
drive a tractor and things like that but
we just
met yeah we met our partners and that
enabled us to do this small dream on a
much bigger scale and we just don't yeah
we thought like 5 10 acres so you know
just to be clear that most people when
they have a
barking dog problem
don't open a farm you see this is what
i'm telling i'm telling solution i tell
this to our couple's therapist all the
time
there are other ways i think the
trajectory of this was
fraught with
issues and it was a dream it was
following a dream to the nth degree and
then in having a dream start to become a
reality it's like
why would you stop that you know and so
then in that then you have to go down
that long and winding road of where it
takes you which is wrought with fear and
doubt and insecurity and all of the
emotional sides that you have to then
develop to be able to get anywhere
i think sometimes it's actually easier
to be courageous for someone else than
it is for yourself it feels
as ridiculous as that sounds that that
was the reason that was the impetus
the courage to save todd
seemed more acceptable than the courage
to live the best possible life for us
and isn't that amazing how how life when
life works that way yeah exactly yeah
like it's all and nature works on this
thing based on consequences not on right
and wrong and so the consequences of our
love for todd and our commitment to todd
as ridiculous as it sounded that
commitment led to this consequential
sort of
life that we get to live
and i like that because i think we learn
that over and over again as farmers that
the more deeply we look into nature the
more we realize it's not about right and
wrong it's about
observing the consequences of our
interactions
well
let's go see your sacred farm you've got
to you've got a little gator out there
to drive us around and we'll we'll do a
little tour let's do it awesome you've
got uh cows and pigs and chickens and
worms and all kinds of stuff for us to
see yeah let's get our hands dirty
all board
[Music]
now we're standing on top of a hill
overlooking some orchards here
um what kind of trees are we looking at
down here
first really important this is allen
york lookout so this is named after alan
our mentor what did you learn from him
and uh
um
and how's that reflected here yeah i
would say
the core value was maximizing
biodiversity
as a way to prevent epidemics of pests
and disease
and by that it means invite nature back
onto the farm
rebuild it as an ecosystem and then try
to
fit a farm within side of a reawakened
ecosystem oh
so it's a little bit passed backwards
exactly build it build a variety of
ecosystems
and then build a farm inside of that
without without creating collateral
damage
and
you know that's the negotiation every
day and be comfortable with a a level of
disharmony
you know um
because ultimately what does that mean
like like we all look for we all look
for perfection in farming and that's why
we're i mean we have a president that
wants to stop a hurricane with a nuclear
bomb
and there's collateral damage from that
idea what's the problem with that
we'll talk about it
and you know i think that's the way we
view farming if there's a pass let's
kill the past but there's a collateral
debt to pay you're killing you know
you're killing bees which are
pollinators you're killing ladybugs
which eat var variety of pests you're
killing wolf spiders you're killing all
these other things that actually help
balance out the epidemic of pests and
disease
but you're making a decision about one
so
ultimately and then it came down to his
very simple philosophy was
cultivate beauty because within this
beauty there is infinite possibility to
collaborate with nature
i mean this is beautiful collaborate
with nature that's a concept
molly what does that mean to you
collaborate with nature collaborate with
nature just means to watch it observe it
to to learn from it before you start to
project your ideas onto it
and um
i mean it's a force much greater than us
so we might want to listen
so he did allen applied then
that to here he actually had come up
here when this was totally ripped out so
there was nothing but dirt and he saw
the contours of the land and then said
one
with a background in vineyards he
thought let's plant on the contours that
helps for multiple reasons with erosion
and also then beauty and then all of the
roads are put where the runoff would be
so it will gather down there someday
we'll have a little uh pond at the
bottom which hasn't quite happened yet
but
we so in here then for to maximize
diversity we have 75 different varieties
20 types so it's
apricots up on the hill nectarines
peaches plums
uh mandarins figs persimmons
pomegranates cherimoya i mean it goes on
and on but it's a delicious spot now you
got some employees coming out of a truck
over here they look like farmer interns
from like
evergreen state college is just true
so what's going on over there that's
actually that those two individuals over
there are specifically focused on the
restoring of habitat we literally use
habitat restoration like preemptive
healthcare
so their job every day is to continue to
go around and see opportunities where we
can infuse native habitat that brings
wildlife back to the farm into the
agricultural
operation
so they're not hippie students they're
professional they're professionals yes
that's ruby hey hippy
that's ruby and lucas
we can bring him over and say hi if you
want yeah but let's see what like what
they're working on now like if it's if
it's yeah they're trying to hey ruby
rebuild the habits
lucas
hi i'm reza hi ruby hi ruby good morning
hi i'm rayne how are you
nice to meet you
how are you nice to meet you lucas hey
rayne how are you lucas nice to meet you
so yeah we were we i we just wanted to
hear about what you guys are working on
in this in the current restoration um
you know process that you're
doing well right now up here we have
this
this pond
right around on this edge where we're
standing there's a meadow restoration
project
so we put some native grass seed in and
we're working on keeping that wet
but in the pond we have these floating
islands that provide habitat for
birds to
have nests all year round
we've got fish in there and
we've got butterflies and yeah
i hear mad chirping down there yeah
there's some crazy yeah there's a lot of
life down there yeah
and it changes throughout the season
sometimes there's migratory birds that
come from like canada all the way down
here and they'll just hang out for the
winter time but this time of year these
are kind of like residents for
summertime
hey milkshakers this podcast is
sponsored by better help and i'm really
psyched that it is because perhaps you
have something interfering with your
happiness or something that is
preventing you from achieving your goals
yeah it's called the world reign the
world is interfering with my happiness
well often times it's the world inside
it's the world inside here the big melon
that that gets in our way and that holds
us back
so betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours this is not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy it's
psychology it's done securely it's
online there is a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime send a message to your therapist
and you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit
in one of those uncomfortable waiting
rooms like you do with traditional
therapy better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
therapists if that's what you need and
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy
plus there's financial aid available
all of this means that betterhelp wants
you to start living a happier life today
so visit their website and read their
testimonials because they're posted
daily visit betterhelp.com milkshake
that's better help and join the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states special
offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
milkshake
hey milkshakers
i have been flying around the world
literally this summer shooting a tv show
i'm often sitting in airplanes with
nothing to do and in waiting rooms
and at airport gates with nothing to do
and thank god
i have discovered the magical world of
best fiends
it's what i do with my free time i get
to open my little game and visit my
little friends my little fiends and we
attack the slugs together be honest rain
what uh what level have you gotten to on
best fiends i'm here i'm i'm cruising
this summer i'm totally cruising i just
crushed level 50 ice halls
where i took on a giant evil slug boss
monster i upgraded all of my little
fiends to prepare and i matched them all
to take out the boss and it was awesome
very good very good oh this is great
because you know as you know i'm trying
to get off of social media because it's
just
depressing me to know and i need
something else to do i need something
else to do with my free time and the
best thing about best fiends is that
it's free to download uh it's this
amazing mobile puzzle game with
thousands of exciting levels for new
adventures and and challenges every
single time you play in fact there are
dozens of unique fiends to collect so
you can customize your team of fiends to
defeat the menacing slugs
power up your favorite fiends to new
levels for even more powerful skills
watch them transform as they get
stronger and
with offline play you'll never be
stranded without fun even if you're on
an airplane in the middle of nowhere
like my friend rain
so listen you've earned your fun time so
go to the app store or google play and
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five
that's friends without the r
best fiends get it
all the board all aboard
okay hang on everybody
yeah tight turn
so we're heading this is the this is the
top secret operation of the farm right
here did you just put some blindfolds on
this is called we call this the vc
we call this the vc the verma compost
center
we'll wait to your tactical team gets in
here this is where the dead bodies are
buried no that's over there oh yeah
so this is a 40-foot worm bin
um it has red wiggler worms in it and so
if you dig in here i think i just saw a
human finger
that was oh okay
wow look at all those worms there's just
a million of them and they live here
this is 40 feet by like four feet
and a little more than that like six
feet and uh
three feet deep of dirt filled with
worms yeah so you you feed on the top
here it's a mixture of um just slightly
composted manure with some juice scraps
with clippings from the farm and then
the worms crawl up to eat and so what
they leave behind is these worm castings
and when the uh material runs through
the body of a worm it increases the
microbial content just immensely and so
that's one method to get more microbes
in the soil oh
look at that so you've got one hand here
with the dirt from the top of the bin
you can see leaves and yeah leaves and
chunks of fruit and things that the
worms will eat and then the soil at the
bottom that has been warmified basically
warm poop yeah warm poop soil uh looks
like really rich loamy
perfect soil so in one basically in what
it's here is like a tablespoon of soil
the finished product
has about nine billion microorganisms in
it
after this process because of that
as it as she says it runs through the
gut of the worm it's putting about 48
different types of bacteria back into
the soil
which is why they always say you know
worms are
kind of the champion
soil builder the unsung champion yeah in
a way isn't the most if you really want
to like have your your corporal life be
of service to the world to like just get
down in there with the worms absolutely
yeah there's because then there's you
could bury a a body
there and fungal communities like
michael risey would seek out the
nutrients of that body as it breaks down
and take those nutrients and feed it to
the root tips of plants in need of those
specific nutrients and it would reward
that fungus for that service of going
through and sort of breaking down your
body
and not not to you know drag things down
here but like uh when you die do you
want to just be you know buried between
the avocado trees it would be great
but there actually is a hole there's
your farm there's there's places that'll
do this it'll bury you
bury you in that way um but yeah you're
right i mean it really is the ultimate
giving back because what we are is a
we're a leather bag of borrowed
nutrients and minerals from the soil
that's all we are it all came from there
everything that we know and are came
through that soil process well rain's
mostly chicken mcnuggets
but yes the rest of us and how did you
guys find your way here
um human leather
a human leather bag a human leather bag
a human leather yeah this is human
leather yeah
i like that nutrients and
human leather purse actually
i would not doubt that
[Music]
obviously we have a lot of conversations
about the way in which human beings have
transformed the earth in in negative
ways but we never talk that much about
the way in which the earth has
transformed human beings right in return
and so i'm curious being this close
right to
the experience of the earth as a single
organism right being this close to it
being
so in touch with the cycle of of nature
how has that
transformed you
spiritually metaphysically i mean yes i
know that you get less sleep and it's a
lot more work and you often smell like
pig [ __ ] but beyond that
i mean
have you had a different
experience
as a human being being in the world yeah
experiencing the human emotional
psychological has that shifted for you
and how i i think for me one of the
really dominant things that it teaches
you because nature is brutal it's really
brutal and
it also is beautiful and magical and all
of those things
but you have to learn how to grieve
and i think that that's
lost a little bit in our culture i heard
once that one of the the most important
things you can do to teach your child is
to teach them how to grieve
and i think that it's very valuable as
i've seen that in myself because you
deal with death
very regularly here you deal with loss
you deal with
all sorts of different aspects and
before i knew how to do that it resulted
in anxiety
and i actually talked to a therapist one
time who said and next time you're
feeling like you're gonna have a panic
of some sort go and ask yourself if
you're sad and i did that and i cried as
soon as you know the sun was going down
that's when the anxiety would come in i
went and sat in a quiet space asked
myself i was sad had a good cry and
moved on and then the panic attacks
never happened again and that you see
that i mean that's a very specific thing
but on the farm you just face that all
the time and when you start to let that
go it's the process of release and i
feel feel like getting to the process of
release is something that we need more
in our culture of it and allows
everything to be renewed again and we
kind of want to stop that pain but that
pain is sort of the core and the crux of
a lot of beauty just just to take it one
step further it's not so much that
because you're constantly surrounded by
things that die
is it also because
you can't help but recognize that
everything here that lives comes from
the carcass of something that died right
absolutely it's everything is completely
impermanent and it even
last night i was having a moment where i
was coming home my parents were just
back in town we had such a wonderful
night and i was recognizing that there
was literally a panic of like i want
this to last forever this feeling to
last forever but then in the fear of
this is can't last forever i was totally
missing the experience of how wonderful
that one second was
and so it's yes it's all around you is
just it's so impermanent and you're so
in touch with how impermanent it is and
how little you can do
to stop that in any way and how out of
control you really are that you're only
your only role is to be in
in relationship with your life rather
than being
the controller of your life then puts
you in a space of humility which allows
so much beauty and emotion and we have
totally
separated ourselves from the pain that's
involved in that but if we can go inside
of that pain we can all experience so
much more truth and beauty so anywho
it's the circle of life one could see
it is the circle of life
i think we teach we teach like we are
encouraging our kids constantly to find
purpose and meaning and the thing that
molly's describing is
the thing that's hardest but brings us
the most joy as farmers is this
reconnection but you have to be willing
to accept that impermanence of life
to fully reconnect with nature
because it's nature on nature's terms
and that reconnection is the thing that
i think for me brought about a whole new
level and way of looking at like who we
are as people and what it means to be
alive because oftentimes you don't want
to reconnect because you don't want to
go through
the anxiety
and the sadness of dealing with
impermanence
[Music]
in
western
um
primarily christian
cultures
the idea of the wilderness
is wrapped around issues of
fear and evil the unknown the mysterious
it
in a way over the last you know five six
hundred years has fostered this bizarre
relationship between
people
and nature in which we have come to
think of nature as something to be
feared
or at best a thing to be controlled
tamed and think about every documentary
that's ever been made about the
environment it
it's divisive in its tactic of fear it
creates a polarization
and an absolute helpless feeling and
that was one of our objectives if we
were going to tell this story it's the
opposite we feel that it all turns on
affection like the change will come in
the more deeply in love we are with our
son to see the possibility beyond the
shortcoming that's right in front of us
like when nature challenges us it's like
your son driving your tractor into the
pond
and then judging that child's ability
and all future
contribution based on that one incident
but when you love nature and you
understand it more deeply you see
infinite possibility beyond the harm
that it presents to us at face value
and so we wanted to create a film that
allowed people to fall in love with
the same thing that we were beginning to
love well i think you've touched on
something that's really important about
the debate around climate change
which is it's very much a debate about
like
should we have coal factories or should
we not or how much should cars be
allowed to pollute or what kind of bills
should we pass and what kind of
international treaty should we sign and
does this going to stunt economic growth
or is it going to help economic growth
all important conversations they're all
part of the conversation but underlying
all of those conversations is
the fact that the western world
especially is completely disconnected
from the earth and from a love of nature
a love of the planet and
a seeing of the the naturalness of the
planet as something beautiful and
necessary and if
humanity especially americans were able
to get more deeply in touch with that
this wouldn't even be
an issue because we would want to be
stewards and caretakers of the earth in
a much
deeper way i mean we're talking about
immune systems being rocked by the
overuse of antibiotics and people are
now trying to be more preemptive in
their health care
and just connect that to what an
ecosystem is a planetary ecosystem is an
immune system and it is fueled by
biological diversity meaning species
diversity
and healthy topsoil those two things are
the regulating bodies of our entire
planet
and without that whether climate change
exists or doesn't i know that the earth
will not be able to respond to epidemics
of pests and disease if we continue to
think that we can live in spite of it
yeah so i mean the probably the greatest
lesson
i would imagine that you've learned in
having this
deep intense relationship with the earth
is
that
the earth itself is a
organism
and
um just like if you have you know too
much duck poop in the
in the pond uh things will go out of
balance but isn't it also the case that
i mean i think you've probably
experienced this that the
that nature the earth has a way of just
fixing itself and the way it fix itself
is by getting rid of the thing that's
the problem
so
all of this is to say
aren't we the problem
and
do you i mean my biggest fear isn't so
much climate change or or you know
things like that my fear is that the
earth at a certain point is just going
to be like you know what [ __ ] you guys
yeah uh
i mean is this is this a thing that
becomes very real and concrete living
here
well i think people often say that
humans are the cancer of the earth and i
think
cancer is a is a cell that figures out
how to turn off the switches that
would
uh end its life at an appropriate time
and it lives forever and replicates
and continues to live without
a consciousness for its dependency on
the host and then eventually the host
dies and so does the cancer
the reality is is that
humans are a force of nature that are
conscious of our dependency and the more
we've become conscious of our dependency
the more we've actually been able to
right the wrongs of economical damage
the faster we've been able to write
those wrongs with a consciousness
to our effect on it so like for example
it took 260 years to lose a third of the
world's top soil deforest 46 of the
trees
right and double our carbon numbers from
200 to 400 parts per million
and on this farm it took 45 years for
them to destroy the soil before we got
it but then with consciousness we
reverse it to better than what it was in
just seven
and so to your point humans
have the potential to be cancer but with
consciousness they can become the
positive human force of nature that they
are part of the uh challenge
in a farm like this
is to
have the strictures necessary right to
control to pen domesticate and all that
stuff but then to allow things to
flourish the animals the the
trees as though they were in the wild
right you're looking for these methods
of biomimicry biologically mimicking the
way
in which nature interacts in a healthy
way
you're looking for these relationships
that are mutualistic
and they're benefiting one another by
coexisting
and that is sort of the basis for
symbiosis
and
those three words really put together as
you begin to look at your decision
making on a farm through those lenses it
really begins to inform the boundaries
and the rules of engagement so we've
talked a lot about
negative aspects of humanity's
disconnection from nature and how much
we can gain from a connection
to the natural cycles
but
where do you see the hope lying you know
the amazon's on fire the arctic it got
up to over 90 94 degrees in the arctic
circle there's more and more
helplessness loneliness anxiety
depression among younger people our
political system seems to be
increasingly more and more broken if
such a thing is possible where does the
hope lie i think as we become more
conscious to
the dependency that we have on the
finite
natural resources of this planet
the more curious we become and how it
works the more
aware we become that this thing is
actually trying to keep us alive
and we become an incredibly potent force
of human nature
when we are conscious of our ability to
work as stewards alongside of it and we
haven't had a ten year period or twenty
or five year period
to experience that as a culture until
now it's happening right now
regenerative agriculture is having an
impact
and it's quantifying the data a one
percent increase in soil organic matter
which we've increased three percent here
on 214 acres a one percent increase per
acre sequesters 21 tons of atmospheric
carbon people didn't know about that
stuff 30 years ago
so i think it's an incredibly hopeful
time to be alive there's a there's this
whole idea about how sustainability
is about
reinvigorating the spiritual connection
that we have uh with the earth right
this idea that
when we distance ourselves from the
source of our food
what we are doing is creating a barrier
uh in our souls almost and
the flip side to that of course is that
the more we mechanize the farming
process right the more it's about
volume um instead of biodiversity which
is you know your whole point here um
it's that what we are doing is allowing
science
to
uh dissolve the sacred
that
there is
that the sacred exists precisely
in our communion with the earth
in the life and death process right in
the planting and the sowing and the
reaping and and and all of that
when i when i'm done every like six
weeks or so seven weeks or so i have to
like get the chickens out of the my coop
and
get all of the the pine shavings and and
poop that they have um and then the very
process of taking that stuff and then
putting it into my garden
and then
having eventually you know cucumbers uh
come out of it and then taking that
cucumber and giving it to my to my son
that experience for him
is
just mind-blowing and it's sacred it's a
sacred experience right it's like it's
where it's where i hope that he will
eventually understand where god lives
you know not in a temple
not a church but
chicken poop inside the chicken poop
okay that's what i'm trying to say is
that god lives in my chicken
that was beautiful
molly have you experienced the sacred on
this farm oh my gosh it's entirely
that's we're it's we're living inside of
what is sacred it's
alive and around us and
this is yeah we're at the we're at the
core of what feels sacred to me and john
i think
so john and molly uh we're gonna start
our our lightning round molly what does
your deathbed look like
oh
um deathbed
uh
i kinda i wanna be outside
um covered in worms yeah not covered or
just nice breeze maybe outside
underneath something and under the shade
of a tree that would be really nice with
my kids and my dogs and kind of just
like living not like it's sick but it's
like where you are right then that would
be nice
john when do you feel most connected
with the universe
when i have discovered
an a way to
solve a problem
on the farm
with something else that also appeared
like a problem and when i'm able to
merge those two things together i feel
like mother nature
molly do you pray yes
often
and sometimes not often sometimes often
always just
not with much formality
sometimes i get on my knees in front of
my bed
um sometimes i get on my knees
in a pasture and sometimes i won't pray
for
a couple months and then it
it just
brings me back to something that i need
john
uh what do you think is the purpose of
your life
i think to find the the deepest form of
reconnection
with the earth and pass that on
molly what's the one thing you know for
sure
oh
what do i know for sure
[Music]
i know
that when i look into my kids eyes i
know that
it's good
it meaning something
bigger
is good
and john
what is your life's big question
really to me like it's so hard to
believe that this planet exists
with the only beings perhaps at least
that we know of that are conscious
of the entire universe
it's got to be something bigger
and so i wonder what that is
but
maybe that's not important
[Music]
reza do you know what the hippest
coolest occupation on the planet is uh
podcast uh host okay good point second
most cool hip occupation on the planet
uh no idea barber
what barbers think when i was a kid
barbers were losers they were old men
usually with no hair
and you get like eight dollars and fifty
cents for you know
trimming people and and whatnot bars or
barbers it was not an occupation you
wanted to brag about but now like in la
and new york a lot of the cities the
hipsterist people are are these barbers
but you know what i think that farmer is
going to supplant uh barber as the
coolest hippest and maybe most important
occupation on the planet yeah i mean i
think looking at
the sort of mechanization of the farming
industry over the last 100 years and
mono farming yeah and that we're now
changing that right that people don't
want that anymore they want the kind of
farming that the chesters are doing and
i think
you know it's not just about the food
it's about the connectivity that
we're living on a single uh ecosystem
that we're intimately a part of it
and
that you know how we live has these
ripple effects for the rest of the
planet you said ripple effects and and i
i that's what i was just thinking about
there's reverberations to what they did
far beyond oh we
went to a farm and we had some travails
and we planted things and now they grow
and now we're farmers
they
had experiences that connected them to
each other to the earth to the natural
world to their souls to their souls to
their purpose i mean
farming kind of gave them a purpose and
a direction and you can just see it in
them they're so
alive
uh with being there and sharing both
what they grow and what they've learned
so i hope uh dear listeners that you
guys were as
impressed and as enthused by uh you know
this uh the story of the chesters and
uh their apricot lane farms as we were
and you know we want to hear from you
how do you
connect with the earth uh do you find
your purpose
in nature tell us about it you can find
us on our socials at raza aslan and at
rayne wilson don't forget hashtag
metaphysical and you can also email us
metaphysical milkshake
soulpancake.com in case you uh have a
longer question or an essay you'd like
to send us yeah and plant a garden
plant a garden people
[Music]
thank you again to our guests molly and
john chester and everyone at apricot
lane farms which apparently you can
actually visit
see you next time so long
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowell sarah
pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin original music by jeff
tang and scott tang
[Music]
by the way i love the the visual element
as you're speaking of watching a cow
[ __ ] um right it's just right in front
of us
but this is here it goes
i wish humans could do that by the way
reza just walk around pooping just yeah
just like if if it's just coming out
just let it go
i mean you could do that right you could
walk around pooping i think it might
damage your acting career
but you could you could help it
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you